one through ten rate yourself as a
dancer
[Music]
say like a five
five I haven't asked you Price is Right
if you literally it's literally like you
made a frog stand up and put jeans yeah
really bad
you know I do squats but it just doesn't
work you you've got an any
[Applause]
it's like your is eating itself
it's like it's going inward like a
Pac-Man
it's just zero ass thanks Mom
[Applause]
now I know the dad's like you've got a
great ass honey
[Applause]
perfect for me I love your ass your ass
is the best ass I've ever seen that
kid yeah
you make up in other areas you're good
yeah
yeah he definitely doesn't say that
still married right yeah he doesn't say
okay now what is the name of your best
dance move it's blender
[Applause]
[Music]
cheeks
[Applause]
right Mom
oh hear me not hear me though
did I told you I would give you a hand
because your parents are here
a lot of times you show a little nip
the crowd responds favorably is all I'm
saying
all I'm saying is you know this is a
crowd response contest
skin to win uh
[Applause]
but there may be a second round so okay
here we go you can take whatever off you
want however
however however however however the baby
bird stays in the nest
[Applause]
the baby bird stays in the nest and you
can't you can't fling it around it's
just gotta be backstage
can't be dancing
in front of people you know what I'm
saying
you can give your mom a lot of pants but
I you have to ask her
all right here we go
Europe ready
good luck remember no touching me okay
all right
felt a weird hover energy
[Applause]
is that
here we go
all right man let's see them titties
here we go ready
[Music]
[Applause]
I Want It That Way
hold on hold on hold on let me let me
just
we just take that in for a second
[Applause]
oh you dolphin
watch up or you can wash up on my
beach anytime
foreign
[Applause]